la France est aux côtés d'Ukraine depuis
le premier jour et le président zenisky
lui-même a toujours voulu discuter avec
le président protéines aujourd'hui il
faut que l'Ukraine puisse résister et
l'emporter et donc nous sommes au côté
de jésus-chreniers des Ukrainiens sans
ambiguïté nous avons
et voilà visite qui est maintenant
terminée le chef de l'État a quitté tout
de suite Pauline Godard Pauline qui est
notre envoyé spécial qui évolue aux
côtés de la délégation française ou
plutôt européenne visite terminée c'est
un déplacement hautement symbolique qui
comme pour tous ceux qui sont passés par
là jusqu'ici Marc les dirigeants
européens être confrontés de cette façon
aux auront la guerre ça évidemment ça ne
s'oublie pas
oui on a fait on a vu un Emmanuel Macron
très ému il a dit c'est triste de voir
la destruction massive d'une ville
européenne j'ai vu des images de ville
dévastées c'est ici que les Ukrainiens
ont arrêté l'armée russe qui
descendaient sur Creuse sur qui elle
vous avez les traces les stigmates de la
barbarie les premières traces de ce que
sont les crimes de guerre alors les
quatre dirigeants sont arrivés ici ils
ont fait un tour de ce quartier nous
nous trouvons exactement au nord-est
dire pin un quartier qui a été
énormément intensément bombardé au début
du mois de mars puisque juste à côté de
moi se trouvait un hôpital militaire
voilà pourquoi ce bombardement était ce
quartier était visé par les bombards de
rue et puis nous nous trouvons également
seulement à quelques kilomètres du de
l'aéroport d'ostomel environ 8 km Cette
aéroport bombardé également lui aussi
sans relâche par les Russes il avait été
c'est ici aussi qu'un des plus gros le
plus gros avion du monde un aéronef
avait été entièrement détruit pendant
les bombardements le président français
vous le savez et là également en tant
que président de l'Union européenne et
il l'a dit vouloir être ici pour montrer
l'unité l'unité européenne et soutenir
qui Ève l'Ukraine vous le savez
également à besoins d'argent c'est aussi
pour ça il a parlé des crimes de guerre
mais ils ont parlé aussi également de la
reconstruction ici l'Ukraine a besoin
d'argent pour reconstruire le pays elle
compte notamment sur l'aide européenne
il est vrai que ce quartier est vraiment
symbolique car quand vous quand vous
vous tournez vous regardez autour de moi
tout a été entièrement détruit les
maisons les immeubles il ne reste
malheureusement que des ruines merci
beaucoup Pauline Godard qui va continuer
à nous faire vivre pendant cette journée
se déplacement puisqu'emmanuel Macron a
donc maintenant et quitté hirpine comme
les autres dirigeants européens ils sont
actuellement en train de d'emprunter de
nouveaux le la route retour vers
verquier 20 mots peut-être Karim et oui
de ce programme on savait qu'il y avait
cette première étape première arrêt à
irpinnes pour l'image évidemment il va y
avoir ensuite ses entretiens avec le
président ukrainien volodiumski qu'on a
pas encore aperçu depuis ce matin
c'est vrai que comme vous l'avez
souligné tout à l'heure il y a une
charge symbolique très forte à se rendre
dans cette ville martyre mais en même
temps pour les Ukrainiens Emmanuel
Macron s'y rend un petit peu tard un
certain nombre de dirigeants notamment
européens y étaient déjà allé au moment
où les Russes savaient reculé et avaient
quitté la zone la zone de Kiev et donc
pour beaucoup c'est un peu une séance de
rattrapage pour Emmanuel Macron et ce et
ceux qui ne l'accompagnent alors
évidemment c'est ces discussions sont
très attendues il y a évidemment les
questions de l'aide militaire et
financière mais il y a aussi la question
de l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne qui va être évoquée il faut
rappeler que au début du conflit un peu
avant le conflit l'Ukraine avec pour
ambition d'intégrer l'OTAN mais tout
tout ça a été balayé par la guerre et
elle s'est tournée finalement vers vers
la dimension politique et vers
l'intégration à l'Union européenne elle
le veut clairement avec force et
Emmanuel Macron a évoqué cette hypothèse
d'une communauté politique européenne en
attendant que l'Ukraine puisse acquérir
le le la possibilité de d'intégrer
l'Union européenne ça ça a été plutôt
mal perçu par les Ukrainiens parce
qu'ils ont eu le sentiment que c'était
une voix de garage alors désormais
Emmanuel Macron un discours un petit peu
plus différent un peu différent en
expliquant que cette adhésion de
l'Ukraine à l'Union européenne c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut envisager de
façon très solide et que cette
communauté politique européenne n'est
pas du tout une voix de garage
simplement quelque chose qui peut
exister en attendant que ce long
processus arrive à son terme c'est sans
doute un des sujets qui sera discuté
tout comme la livraison d'armes c'est
vrai qu'Emmanuel Macron a été beaucoup
critiqué c'est ces dernières semaines et
ces derniers mois du côté de l'Ukraine
pour ne pas être venu suffisamment tôt
il faut rappeler que la France est à la
présidence de l'Union européenne encore
15 jours seulement et du côté ukrainien
on a parfois le sentiment qu'il est venu
parce que il fallait le faire avant que
que la France ne soit plus présidente de
l'Union européenne et puis il y a eu des
mots qui ont été mal perçus côté
ukrainien lorsque Emmanuel Macron a
expliqué qu'il ne fallait pas humilier
la Russie alors que les autres étaient
en train de visiter Bucha ou irpin alors
que le président américain était en
train de parler de génocide et
clairement il y a une volonté de la part
d'Emmanuel Macron de balayer ce
malentendu parce que en réalité c'est
beaucoup plus les mots d'Emmanuel Macron
que la politique française qui a été mal
perçue en Ukraine il s'en est d'ailleurs
de nouveau réexpliquer tout à l'heure à
airpn puisqu'interroger par les
journalistes l'accompagner voici sa
réponse il faut que l'Ukraine puisse
résister et l'emporter nous nous tenons
aujourd'hui sans ambiguïté aucune aux
côtés des U